pandémie ou pas les avions décollent à
cette nuance près des dizaines de
milliers d'entre eux voleront à vis de
cette saison un véritable scandale
écologique
la compagnie allemande lufthansa a
déclaré fin décembre devoir faire voler
18000 appareil sans passagers air
bruxelles 3000 en revanche air france
s'y refuse les compagnies ont recours à
cette pratique du vol à vide pour
conserver leurs créneaux horaires
suivants une réglementation fixée par la
commission européenne qui rappelons le
voeu décarbonés l'économie mais bien sûr
l'aviation est un secteur
particulièrement sinistré depuis
l'arrivée du coc vide faute de
réservations par manque de personnel
devenu qu'un contact ou malades lors de
la vague du omicron pas moins de dix
mille vols ont été annulés entre noël et
le jour de l'an mais si une compagnie là
ses avions au sol elle perd ses créneaux
de vol c'est la loi cette réglementation
a été mise en place car les créneaux de
vols sont très convoités et une
compagnie pour en réserver 1 et ne pas
l'utiliser juste pour empêcher un
concurrent de s'y déployer pour cette
compétition loyale il y à peu il fallait
faire voler 80% des avions pour
conserver son créneau ce seuil a été
abaissé à 50% par bruxelles à cause du
coc vide mais il a encore été relevé en
décembre par la commission européenne à
64% mesure qui entrera en vigueur à
partir de mars alors que la pandémie
fait toujours rage il faudrait pourtant
encore le diminuer pour rester cohérent
avec la mission de protection de
l'environnement que s'est assigné la
commission européenne georges gilkinet
ministre belge de la mobilité des
transports a dénoncé un non sens
économique écologique et social
il a demandé mercredi la commissaire
européenne aux transports a dit la
vallée and d'abaisser le seuil il y
aurait donc peut-être une sortie de
crise mais en prenant la commission
européenne en étau et cette polémique a
rebondi encore davantage à la suite des
déclarations de l'association
représentant les aéroports européens
jeudi 6 janvier la cia europe explique
les compagnies aériennes n'ont aucune
raison de faire voler des avions à vide
sur le continent pour conserver leur
credo dans un communiqué incendiaire
elle estime que le pourcentage fixé à 50
et raisonnable car il existe une autre
mesure adaptée à la situation voici un
élément de leur communiqué il y as en
place une mesure spécifique que les
règles tentation des créneaux des
aéroports mondiaux appelée la clause de
non utilisation justifier des créneaux
elle couvre non seulement les
interdictions de voyager pure et simple
mais aussi des restrictions de mouvement
des mesures de quarantaine au
d'isolement qui affecte la viabilité ou
la possibilité de voyager ou la demande
sur certaines liaisons alors qu
association de compagnies aériennes et
associations aéroportuaire se
contredisent par voie de presse une
seule certitude c'est encore le climat
qui va trinquer en 2011 on estimait que
le secteur aérien et est responsable de
3 5% de la création de gaz à effet de
serre alors d'un réchauffement
climatique global qui commence à créer
des famines comme à madagascar ces vols
à vide sont un peu la métaphore des
mesures environnementales de l'union
européenne de l'extérieur ça en jette
mais n'y a rien dedans